the lifeless monster is a being that
created by a whole bunch of caricaturist
but it's interesting that virtually
anybody unless their professional
historian writing about the
Enlightenment anybody throwing out
discussions about the Enlightenment
whether it be Robert Kagan on the right
or gee I don't know who on the left
Foucault on the left whoever it is sees
the enlightenment as an ISIL a cold
being who has sublimated all passion to
reason who believes that reason is
instrumental and calculating and a
matter of Technology who has a blind
faith in progress and things that the
world is inexorably going forth for the
better what's what are some other
features of the Enlightenment monster
those are the crucial ones they don't
actually fit anyone which is why I
called them the Enlightenment monster in
the book because if you look at the
Enlightenment itself and you don't need
to be historian and you don't need to
dig into the archives all you need to do
is read Candide which was written in
1759 that is in the middle of the
Enlightenment by Voltaire you see a
critique of this very simplistic
enlightenment attitude from the heart of
the Enlightenment itself that is the
Enlightenment itself knew that progress
wasn't necessary they only thought it
was possible they knew that other things
besides reason were important they spent
at least as much time talking about the
emotions as they did about reason and
they weren't interested in reason
because they were icy or because they
were merely technological but because
reason was a Democratic instrument
against superstition and authority
reason is opposed not to passion but to
somebody's intuition right just as well
God told me to invade another country so
that's a private intuition and there's
no way that I can explain it to you but
I just know it is one way of not using
reason another way of not using reason
is is to simply use rhetoric to simply
use sound bites play
same sound bites over and over without
looking at an entire speech in context
and to create superstition and fear and
the Enlightenment was attempting to use
reason which is a faculty we all have we
can all develop and we can all debate
about as I gather you're doing with this
program rather than appealing to
authority or superstition so all of
those all this criticism of the
Enlightenment occurred within the
Enlightenment itself the idea the other
feature of the Enlightenment of course
is that people think it was totally
irreverent and anti religious it was not
irreverent it most members of the
Enlightenment there's some who were
sheer atheists and who I even would call
irreverent lacking a sense of reverence
that I do think isn't terribly important
but most of them thought that science
would lead to a greater appreciation of
the glories of creation and gratitude
for the fact that we live in a marvelous
world that was how they saw science as
as contributing to human progress not
simply although these are important
enough helping to eradicate disease and
poverty and prejudice but also in
creating a sense of wonder and gratitude
i stress about for enlightenment values
because i don't simply think that
there's one one of the things that when
people associate something positive with
the enlightenment which unfortunately is
rare enough these days they talk about
tolerance tolerance is fine as far as it
goes if you already believe in something
but it's deeply wimpy in the sense that
you might conceivably get somebody to
refrain from doing something in the name
of tolerance you will have a very hard
time getting them to do anything for
something in the name of tolerance
because it's not a value that has a lot
of content so instead I've asked that we
look at four different enlightenment
values one I named you already which is
reason the other is reverence which I
also discussed a third which we've come
to take for granted is happiness I think
it's very easy for fundamentalist to
look at American consumerist culture and
we've seen terrorists do that and say
you know what this is not my idea of the
meaning of life of society that's
consumed with whoever dies with the most
toys wins as a bumper sticker in the 90s
used to say there's something revolting
about that as a sense of value that's
not what the Enlightenment was talking
about about sheer materialism the
Enlightenment was talking about a right
to happiness as distinguished from
whatever fate you got stuck with i
started my chapter on happiness with the
book of Job which may seem like a
counterintuitive place to start and I
started that way because the book of Job
is the most read book of the Bible but
until the Enlightenment everyone who
read job read him the way jobs friends
did that is job had it coming okay and
they went to crazy lengths to try and
construct a story such that job deserved
whatever it is that he got in the
Enlightenment
suddenly began to have a notion that hey
actually it would be possible for bad
things to happen to good people and good
things to happen to bad people this is
not what God has ordained and what that
means is if bad things happen to good
people the world people in the world
have a right to step up and try to
change them you say before you have that
idea if people were sick well you know
it was probably God's will if people
were poor hey that was certainly God's
will so until you have the idea that
happiness is not something in a lost
golden age or something that you might
look forward to in heaven but something
that if you fundamentally do what you
should do you have a right to on earth
until you have that idea you don't get a
sense of justice so that's the third
enlightenment value and the final one is
the value of Hope which is very
different from optimism the people in
the Enlightenment were not sunny they
knew how bad things could be if you read
some of these pieces you'll be amazed
they sound like they could be written in
the late 20th century as far as their
understanding of just how dark human
beings could be so they don't believe
that human beings are perfect they just
don't believe that they're committed to
original sin and interestingly enough I
think both a lot of traditional
Christians as well as a lot of secular
postmodernists and this is very
interesting someone like Foucault is
actually talking or he doesn't talk
about it of course but he's actually
giving us as a foundation an ocean of
original sin whatever one tries to do to
improve on the world is doomed to
futility because in fact we're all
driven by nothing but power and whatever
looks like an alleviation of injustice
is in fact going to be a refinement of
certain techniques of power so when the
Enlightenment does away with those kinds
of ideas of original sin I'm
that's a postmodern return to original
sin they're saying you know what things
can get better and I think our own time
has seen so many clear ideas so many
clear examples of ways in which the
world has been changed by ideals for the
better but not necessarily torture is a
very good example if you think about the
fact that 300 years ago scenes that
would turn your stomach to read about
are things you would have taken your
kids to watch on a Saturday afternoon
and you realize well that was in the
heart of civilization we've abolished
that now of course as we've seen in the
last five years this is not necessary
progress you can turn the clock back and
one of the things that has to happen to
restore America's moral authority is for
us to take a resounding stand again
against torture and for the
Enlightenment but is a kind of progress
it happened it doesn't happen
necessarily but it can happen but if we
work toward
you